this is a production of Cornell
University
so good morning everyone obviously this
is not my main line of work I don't do a
lot of presentations so I'm going to do
the best I can to work through this
um as Jenny said I've been working for
about 25 years with dairy farms all over
New York State on both environmental and
facility planning projects
so we do a lot of manure storage design
I'm going to go ahead and
go through a little bit of an outline of
what I'd like to discuss since we do do
a lot of storage design I wanted to talk
a little bit about storage design
considerations and how that can affect
the cover design and what types of
storages are easier to cover and site
limitations that prevent those some of
those easier to cover options sometimes
we're going to talk about storage cover
design considerations
obviously what type of storage you're
covering matters but also what are your
goals for your cover
oh sorry some examples of new storages
with covers in mind manure transfer in
and out
the siding and the Topography of that
manure storage is going to matter a
great deal
examples of some retrofits and issues
encountered after installation so first
we'll go talk about the storage General
design considerations
um
obviously when we're sizing a storage or
when we're designing a store is the very
first thing that matters to us is as
Engineers is size what is the capacity
we're going to need what type of animals
do you have what type of waste are they
generating
um other sources other than just the
standard manure that you're going to be
putting into this system including say
for Dale on a dairy farm you're looking
at milking Center waste likely silage
leachate control things that are going
to affect the overall size of that
storage
bedding material also affects what this
storage is going to look like
tremendously you heard Dale kind of talk
about a few different types of bedding
they've used in the past one that is
pretty popular in New York state is sand
sand bedding does affect a manure
storage design more than any other type
of bedding so if you bed with sand you
either have to have a very extensive
sand separation system or you need a way
to get into your manure storage and
remove that sand
um if you're betting with solids and
sawdust
you know you can re-agitate those
materials from above and don't
necessarily need the access to the
manure storage
you also notice that Dale pointed out
rightly so that separation is a huge
part of any any system that's going to
have a cover in it so is that something
that you're you're willing to look at
site conditions
we look really closely at those in New
York state especially because nrcs has
come out with new requirements
relatively new within the last five
years if you're over certain types of
Bedrock or over aquifers you're required
required to do an enhanced design which
would either include a synthetic liner
or enhanced concrete structure sometimes
that can limit us limit us on our
options for manure storage capacity and
location
and then you need to look at some other
things what's your topography what's
that going to do to your storage design
am I in a hillside am I on the flats
um some man-made obstacles that some
people don't always think about overhead
power lines and right-of-ways for those
as well as pipelines
um give us
obstacles to work around and locations
sometimes we end up having to pump or
move a storage where we weren't really
planning on because of those issues
um and then solid separation is it are
you planning on doing that
um as Dale said that is something that
takes management operation
um
and
is sometimes cost prohibitive for a
smaller farmer
um to have a solid separation system
just for you know 100 cows or less
and then
when we're doing the manure storage will
it be covered and that's kind of what
we're going to go over today what are
the design considerations for that
manure storage if it's going to have a
cover in place
foreign
so storage design considerations what
type of storage so in New York state we
do mainly three types of storages
Earthen and in that I would consider
Earthen with both a clay liner and a
synthetic liner so that would be the
Earthen storage option
concrete storages most of those are a
vertical walled structure in New York
state and then we do do some slurry
store type structures which are the
glass two Steel type structures those
each of those structures has their own
benefits and drawbacks with the Earth
and storage
um there are easily much more easily
covered the concrete storages can be
covered in certain situations but it's a
little bit more difficult and then the
slurry store structures uh tend to have
a size limitation so they can be covered
solar store actually makes a cover that
goes right on those but they have a
limitation on size of those structures
when you're when you're designing a
manure system thinking think about what
your storage pumps do you have existing
storage pumps what kind of a riser do
you want do you want to be able to pump
into and out of the storage from a riser
do you want to pump in and out at
surface things like that are going to
matter to you distance to electrical
service which didn't used to be an issue
but if you want to be able to pump out
of a risers sometimes those are an
electrical submersible pump
um also if you're going to be covering a
structure Dale's structure Dale's Flair
was um solar powered but a lot of the
flare companies do prefer to have a
direct connect to an electrical service
and also the water the pumps for the um
rain water also it's easier if you have
a direct electrical service
you also need to be thinking about
sources of contamination near the cover
so Dale's storage is next to his bunk
Silo there is a potential for
silage leachate to develop on the cover
from silage that is blown on from the
function of its adjacent you also could
have issues with bedding salads if
you're betting solids building is near
your cover those are some things to keep
in mind
um and then gas collection and potential
flare location so the gas collection
needs to be calculated carefully so when
you
when you're designing your system you
have to design it for a certain amount
of gas it's going to come off calculated
based on the number of animal units
going in an ambient temperature
sometimes you can need a blower to
deliver the gas to the flare the other
thing to think about is that gas is a
wet gas so in order to send it to the
flare you need to run it through a
Content condensate trap and it's
beneficial if you can put that flare
upslope from the manure storage so that
when you run the gas through you can
actually Gravity the condensate back
and then water exclusion we've talked
about the rain water and the pumps out
of the system but you also need to make
sure when you this goes for a manure
storage or a covered manure storage that
your clean water exclusion system which
may include a diversion upslope is
functioning well and designed
appropriately and we'll go over that a
little bit later I'll talk about a cover
that was put in and then we immediately
had five feet of rain water on top of it
due to a
one of those large storms we seem to be
getting in New York State anymore
so I think what we'll do now is go
through a cover installation
kind of start to finish this is a cover
that was installed in Erie County Alan
Young from Erie County Soil and Water
took all of these pictures for me during
installation
this was a retrofit on an existing
manure storage and we'll kind of just go
through the steps that were taken on
this particular storage first
I'm going to use my mouse here so this
picture up here in the upper left hand
corner is a manure Riser and pipe into
the bottom of the structure so one thing
to think about when you're doing a
manure storage
either retrofit or a new design is that
the cover needs to be sealed and how are
you going to get manure into and out of
the structure
this pipe going in on the bottom creates
a liquid seal the manure level is above
this pipe so they can pump in and pull
out whenever they'd like without opening
the cover or breaking that seal over
here on the right hand side you can see
this is the manhole structure pipe going
out of the bottom and they can introduce
from the top or put a pump in the top to
pull back out again oh shoot
that just there
um
down here in the lower left hand corner
you can see they're getting the cover
ready for installation so one thing to
think about when you're covering is you
need space to be able to weld the cover
together off to the side and then pull
it over the storage so you need a pretty
big space to be able to accomplish that
over here on the lower right you can see
that they are welding together Dale
talked about the concrete weights on his
cover so all those are pieces of cover
material welded together and filled with
concrete to make the troughs to collect
the water
foreign
this is the um we'll start here actually
in the lower left
one of the things to think about when
you're putting on a cover is how how
many solids will be in there so you're
going to have separation which we talked
about
even when you separate there are some
solids that make it through that system
how are you going to reentrain those
solids if you feel it's an issue so some
separation systems are such that we
don't put in these recirculation lines
this this manure storage has
recirculation lines that you can see go
through the bottom of the store
structure and up to the surface so those
get installed first
and then you can see
the um
stabilization trench is put around the
outside of the structure
this is fabric just to protect the liner
as it goes up and down on the surface or
the cover I'm sorry the cover as it goes
up and down on the surface and the pipe
you can see here is the gas collection
line you can see it here with strapping
that'll hold it in place
and then in this upper right hand corner
you can also see one of the things you
need to think about as well if it's an
existing system is how do I seal around
existing penetrations this is silage
lyche which I had mentioned before
liquid coming from the runoff at the
bunk silo
comes through this pipe and now because
it's buried and will be under the cover
that will create the airtight seal that
we need
and it's below the obviously below the
stabilization trench that stabilization
trench I'll show some pictures in a
minute but that's where the anchor the
cover gets anchored
the bottom right here you can see um
they're just starting to pull that cover
across so the picture we saw in the
beginning was back here was staged
they're now pulling it across with
equipment
foreign so why am I missing hang on
here we go they've pulled it across more
they're pulling it across a little bit
more in this picture they float it right
across the manure storage when there's
liquid in there so you don't have to
have it all of the way empty you have to
have it at a specific level for them to
pull up pull it across that's part of
the planning process that Dale talked
about you need to make sure that um
they can your liquid level will be at
the appropriate level for them to cover
when they're able to come
this is the stabilization trench you can
see that the cover goes down in back up
and then they back fill it with concrete
this is just the cover as it comes all
the way across and then here it is here
they are finishing up back filling that
Trench
so now that we've done that I think
we'll go through
um that was a retrofit I have some just
some aerial use of some some systems
that we've worked on that I'd like to go
through kind of point out some issues
that we've had
um as time has gone on so this is a
manure storage that was designed and the
cover installed at the same time roughly
so you I mentioned you have to have
liquids in here so the storage was
installed a liner was put in this has a
synthetic liner as like Dales which Dale
was showing you in his photo and then
the cover was put on several months
later after the liquid level was such we
could float the cover across
so one of the things when you're
designing a manure storage with a
synthetic liner you need to design that
core Trench
differently than if it's a if it's going
to have a cover then if it's not so if
you don't have a cover a synthetic liner
just
has a core trench that's back filled
with Earth whereas if we're going to put
a cover on the top eventually you want
to back fill that with concrete small
changes like that in the design
you also I talked about the manhole
structure this was designed with a
manhole structure
from the beginning so this didn't have
to be put in later there's a manhole
structure here and then the pipe goes
out into the bottom of the storage right
here
Miss storage also because of this
manhole structure and this is an
electric submersible pump this pumps to
a remote Loadout that's about 1500 feet
away from the manure storage
this Farm has a
remote Loadout here with a
self-contained system for spillage
you can also see in this drawing around
this photo the
clean water collection here
and then the rain water pumps
are discharging they do not discharge
Dale discharge and collects
this storage just discharges to the
surface to clean water
so we talked about the the manhole this
is actually the finished manhole for the
project that I originally showed you
it was a retrofit so this was installed
later they had they originally pumped
over top of the manure storage structure
to to load and unload and this was a
retrofit to allow us to cover this is
just another version of the same thing
but this is a circular manhole that's a
little bit smaller
with a circular discharge pipe and this
is another view of that same structure
just to give you an idea what that looks
like you do have to cite this so that
the cover can the stabilization trench
for the cover can go between that and
the top wall of the manure top of the
wall of the manure storage
so I'm going to now go through some
retrofits this is the first retrofit
that we did in 2009 this is a two manure
storage is covered with one you can see
they have solid storage around here
and the liquids from that go into here
and then they covered these two storages
so
there are some storages for because of
solids that will not be able to be
covered or it would be very difficult to
cover but this Farm has chosen to cover
the ones that were easier to cover
this Farm was the very first one we did
and they did not have a way to get
manure into or out of the structure
without going over the surface and did
not do a retrofit you look very
carefully where these arrows are
pointing you can see access ports so
when they need to get manure out of this
structure they go and open a port on top
of the manure storage and then put the
pump in there
um
you can see the rain water's collecting
clean rain water collected here
the ports are to me are a little bit of
a safety issue because you're standing
over the manure storage opening a port
where gases can escape at you when
you're opening the port prefer the
manhole type structures
this is another retrofit done in 2010
you can see the manhole structure
here in the corner
that was retrofit so this also was a
retro that we put the manhole structure
in you can see the stabilization room
for the stabilization trench we try to
leave about five feet there this was a
Earthen line structure so we had to
repair the Earth and liner when we put
this in
the manhole was installed here in 2010
the other thing when you're installing a
cover
It generally discharges to the flare
however
the emergency there needs to be an
emergency relief valve so that if
something happens with this flare
there's a way for the gas to escape the
system and not build up
this Farm has a circulation manifold
here so he has the circulation lines
that I showed you previously on the
install pictures and he chose to put a
manifold together so that he can just
turn valves to be able to recirculate
manure through his system
this is another retrofit done in 2011.
on this one you can really see the gas
build up just because of the time of
year that the photo was taken
this also has a retrofit for the um
manhole and line in that was installed a
lot of the storage is built in the tooth
early 2000s late 1990s
um had an over the bank discharge into
the storage and then just a pump Drive
in to pull manure out
this is the flare location flare
location
needs to be at least 75 feet from the
storage
so sometimes that can be a bit of a
challenge depending on your site
and then here's your emergency relief
valve over here on that particular
storage
this actually is a picture of Dales
cover that was done in 2012.
rainwater discharge points that you can
see here that flare location that he had
here and the main reason I wanted to
show this there was a couple different
things on this site
one we had to this was a retrofit and
they had these access pumps pump pump
out locations installed before the cover
went on
so to to attach that instead of just
going into a stabilization trench you
have to come up with a way to seal that
to the concrete so this is just the
detail that we use to seal it to the
concrete but definitely something to
keep in mind
and then the other reason I wanted to
show it was
the potential for
silage leaves to get down onto this
cover and potentially contaminate that
cupboard something you really need to
think about during design
but also if you're going to be
discharging that water you need to be
thinking about Dale collects all of his
and uses it for irrigation so there's no
issue there but if he was discharging
that to clean water it's something when
you're turning those pumps on you need
to really pay attention to
this is the finished product of the
retrofit
that I showed you all the photos of you
can see a lot of gas production on this
one
this is another retrofit with solid
separation installed so this Farm did
not separate solids they installed the
separation building
flare location here
access point here
that was installed in 2016.
prior to the cover in 2017.
and then this is the one I was talking
about where we had an issue with clean
water exclusions which is the version
here this is the North George priority
cover because I could not get a photo
recent enough to show the cover this is
a retrofit in 2020.
there was a diversion here that had
silted in that diversion carried all the
clean water from this Hillside around
the manure storage
and when it's silted in
they had just installed this cover and
we had a five inch rainfall in about an
hour and a half in this location and
they ended up with five feet of water
that's why the cover looks dirty on top
that's all silk from the hillside that
came in about five feet deep
um and the cover was not even the pumps
weren't even installed yet so it was a
real wake-up call to the farm how much
water they could have potentially been
adding extra every time we had a
rainfall event to their storage and we
obviously took care of that diversion at
the same time this one also that flare
location is upslope that's was a nice
sight we put the flare location upslope
and were able to drain the condensate
right back into the storage
foreign
so this is the issues we were talking
about potential contamination
contaminants from the surrounding areas
I wanted to kind of go just give you an
overview of some of the issues that
we've seen
this is Dale's again the silage issue we
talked about and then this is the double
cover with the manure solid stacked
right here when the wind blows there's a
potential for those mineral solids to
get right onto that cover
this is the storage that was installed
from new down here on the bottom
and you can see if you look closely the
the color in this clean water collection
trench and the color in this clean water
collection trench do not match
um this cover received damage in the
springtime from an ice sheet so it was
the ice had built up on the side ice
sheet fell down and perforated the cover
so the installer came back and repaired
it so there was no issue but they had to
pump this rain water obviously back into
their manure system
me
this cover
um they had some issues with the flare
when they first started up so one of the
harder things to do this is an Earthen
storage no synthetic liner
and they had leaks around the
stabilization trench where for one
reason or another it did not seal well
so they weren't getting enough gas
production to make the flare run
consistently so that was all repaired
and now is working fine but that was an
issue with that site
and this is the one I was showing you
with all the gas production over here at
the bottom right you can see how high
that is not how a cover should look
um this site had excessive gas
production a couple of different issues
the separation was not working well and
so there was excess solids in there but
even calculating that out there's an
anomaly here that we still have yet to
figure out exactly why there was so much
gas production in this storage
um
it is in a location where it sits over
here there's a natural gas well and this
storage when they constructed it prior
to my involvement did hit Shale in this
lower corner that was lined with um clay
maybe there's some something there I
don't know but that's something one of
those issues that you need to keep in
mind when you're doing things and why
it's so very important to have an
emergency relief valve
so that concludes
my presentation
I'm going to stop sharing the screen
Jennifer
all right
so thank you so much Jennifer I just
Jessica
thank you so much that was fantastic
presentation
um we are running low on time but there
are a couple questions uh I wanted to
see if we could field
um is there a book estimate of the cubic
feet of methane per cow from a covered
storage or potential BTU per cow if a
flare is utilized for energy use like
how do you do those calculations for how
much gas is going to be produced there
is a book value that I don't know off of
the top of my head
um that we use when we calculate that
and it does depend on separation and how
much separation you have and how
efficient your separation is what that
number is but it does need to be
calculated so that you can decide
whether or not you need a blower to
deliver
the gas more quickly to the flare
and it helps you size obviously the
lines to the flare the blower itself and
the flare
fantastic
um
how so John asks how are we dealing with
covers and flares on steel and concrete
takes compared to Earthen goons we've
done none in New York that I'm aware of
of the steel ones steel and concrete or
concrete
um so concrete poses some issues with
covering Earthen are very easy to cover
concrete you have the vertical sides the
only time we've tried to cover one was
for
rain water control and so we could
figure out a way to do that but not a
way to make it reliably sealed to the
top of the tank for a gas collection so
we have not done one of those yet and
same with the slurry store we just
haven't come across it where we've
anybody has wanted to put a flare on a
slurry store so I'm certain it could be
done but it's not something we've done
yet
okay
um if you if you want to answer any of
those questions in the chat by text
please do but I also know that you need
to leave so thank you so much Jessica
that was a super presentation I'm I'm so
happy we could have you join us today
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu